y un clamor que recorría las calles de
cataluña desde noviembre de 2017 que se
unió barcelona en llamas tras las
sentencias que quedaron en firme en
octubre de 2019
la justicia española decretó entonces
entre 9 y 13 años de cárcel a nueve
líderes independentistas catalanes entre
ellos el ex presidente de cataluña
carles puigdemont exiliado en bélgica y
el exvicepresidente oriol junqueras este
lunes el presidente del gobierno español
pedro sánchez confirmó que mañana
propondrá su indulto en el consejo de
ministros por eso mañana pensando en el
espíritu constitucional de concordia
propondré al consejo de ministros
conceder el indulto a los nueve
condenados en el juicio del procés que
hoy están en prisión pero vamos a hacer
y lo vamos a hacer por la concordia
lo vamos a hacer con un corazón sin
embargo el anuncio no es del total
agrado de los independentistas su
petición siempre ha sido la amnistía y
no el indulto esto es un no auto indulto
el estado español excarcelar a unos
presos políticos que no deben haber
pasado ni un día en la cárcel para pere
aragonès actual presidente de la
generalitat los indultos suponen un
gesto para retomar los diálogos pero
siguen siendo insuficientes una amnistía
beneficiaría a unas 3.000 personas
involucradas en los eventos de 2017
esta decisión cabo ya anunciado esta
decisión que hoy ha anunciado el
presidente del gobierno español no
aporta ninguna solución a una represión
que va mucho más allá y que afecta a
decenas y decenas de responsables
públicos pero también de ciudadanos
afectados por esta causa general contra
el independentismo contra la linda
pandan tisma los indultos también
cuentan con un rechazo mayoritario de la
sociedad española las encuestas señalan
que un 60 por ciento de los españoles se
oponen a la liberación de los
independentistas catalanes